hallo ihr lieben wir machen heute ein
knackiges und kurzes rezept nämlich für
meinen ultimativen eiscafé das rezept
habe ich schon auf instagram geteilt
weil ich gedacht okay das ist so kurz
das rezept dafür lohnt sich das
youtube-video gar nicht jetzt denke ich
ganz anders denn nachdem ich das
gepostet habe wurde ich überflutet mit
eurem fotos und das kam so gut an dass
ihr das teilweise jeden tag aufs neue
gemacht habt hier bin ich euch gerne mal
einfach fotos von euch ein
und falls sie noch instagram noch nicht
folgt dann schnell rüber dort findet ihr
immer wieder neues und aktuell sind
könnte auch ganz oft mit bestimmt was
ihr auf youtube so abgeht und ich zeige
euch jetzt die zutaten für unser
leckeres eis café wir benötigen café den
habe ich gerade frisch gekocht außerdem
eine eiswürfel form unserer wahl milch
hier habe ich die frische fettarme
genommen und vanilleeis
wir bereiten zuallererst unsere café
eiswürfel vor
dafür gehen wir einfach den aufgebrühten
kaffee in unserer eiswürfel formen und
lassen das ganze erhärten allerdings
möchte ich noch kurz den hinweis geben
falls die frage kommt ihr könnt
filterkaffee verwenden löslichen den aus
der maschine cappuccino alles was ihr
möchtet hauptsache kaffee lass dir nur
ganz kurz abkühlen dann ein gießen und
dann gefrieren lassen
nachdem eure café eiswürfel eingefroren
sind können wir auch schon loslegen
deshalb mache ich mir die immer einen
abend vorher und zwar auf vorrat dann
kann ich mir immer wieder zum leckeren
eis kaffee machen wir geben die jetzt in
unser lieblings glas und dann zeige ich
euch die es weitergeht
als nächstes geben wir zwei esslöffel
vanilleeis hinein und hier könnt ihr
auch jeder an reissorte eurer wahl
nehmen als nächstes stießen wir das
ganze mit unserer milch auf wie gesagt
habe ich hier die fettarme frischmilch
ihr könnt auch sojamilch nehmen oder
kokosmilch alles was sie möchte
und eigentlich ist euer eiscafé jetzt
fertig den ganzen sommer lang habe ich
ihnen so genossen aber falls jetzt mal
ganz besonderen tag habt oder gäste oder
euch einfach mal verwöhnen möchtet dann
gibt noch ein bisschen frische sahne
drauf wirklich ganz einfach steif
geschlagen ohne süßungsmittel und gäbe
anschließend noch ein bisschen bei kakao
darüber
und fertig ist ein eiscafé deshalb habe
ich immer kaffee eiswürfel auf vorrat
bei mir im gefrierschrank dann falls ihr
das mal nicht haben so richtig lust auf
diesen eiscafé habt dann ärgert ihr euch
denkt hat damit hätte ich jetzt mal die
kaffee eiswürfel denn das ist eigentlich
das was jetzt am längsten brauch und der
ist superschnell gemacht ich probiere
jetzt noch mal für euch weiß das schon
lecker das schmeckt aber euch zu liebe
ja lecker super erfrischend und ich mach
das mal ganz gerne bei warmem wetter
aber ich kann mir das im winter auch
ganz gut vorstellen in dem winter ist
man ja auch weiß also warum nicht so ein
richtig leckeren eis café falls ihr das
rezept nicht schon nach gemacht habt
dann freue ich mich trotzdem weiterhin
über fotos mit dem hashtag ich dies
kitchen auf instagram folgt mir dort
abonniert mich hier kostenlos dann
verpasst ihr hier auch kein video mehr
hinterlassen video gerne ein like und 1
kommentar mit eurem feedback und dann
sage ich bis zum nächsten mal auf die
gis kitchen tschüss und ich bin mit den
jetzt weiterhin